У цьому маленькому ресторанчику в Солом’янському районі Києва
раді кожному клієнту, навіть якщо той замовив лише порцію солянки.
Через коронавірус кухня простоює, зали порожні.
А зміни до податкового законодавства, в результаті яких ресторан має перейти на роботу з касовими чеками,
можуть взагалі добити її бізнес, вважає власниця Світлана Кравченко.
З наступного року вона як ФОП другої категорії з щорічним обігом менше мільйона гривень
має встановити касовий апарат або, як його зараз називають, РРО - реєстратор розрахункових операцій.
І на все видавати касові чеки. Наразі вона працює на спрощеній системі оподаткування, бухгалтера в неї немає.
Овочі та м'ясо купує не в супермаркетах з чеками, а на ринках або в селян.
Бабуся на ринку не може видати мені документ, і чека в неї немає, але продукція в неї якісніша.
Тому стоїть вибір: купувати в магазині чи купити в бабусі. Я би краще купувала в бабусі.
Зараз я повинна буду щодня думати, де мені взяти документи, як мені правильно зробити, щоб я не зробила якоїсь помилки.
Тому що якщо я буду робити помилки, то буде великий штраф.
Касові апарати знищать дрібний та середній бізнес. Громадський рух SaveФОП виступає за відтермінування
або взагалі скасування введення касових апаратів.
Передусім для дрібного бізнесу: маленьких крамничок, перукарень, майстерень, фермерів та фрілансерів.
Підприємці вважають, що нові правила - услід за карантином - доб'ють їхній бізнес і підстьобуватимуть корупцію серед податківців.
Я працювала 5 років з касовим апаратом. Я змушена була закрити відділ, тому що раз у рік,
коли бузьки (лелеки) летять в Україну, до нас у магазин залітали податківці. Коли вони перетинають поріг магазину,
то з магазину не виходять без грошей. І одразу починається домовляння, мовляв, що нам починати шукати?
І повірте мені, вони знають, що шукати . І ти стоїш, як злочинець, і не знаєш, що маєш робити.
Маю магазин, у мене побутова хімія, косметика, парфумерія. У мене в одному відділі 1500 найменувань.
Скажіть мені, будь ласка, як я можу без помилки в день пропрацювати? Це в мене вже наперед закладений штраф!
Ми повертаємося в 90-ті роки! Зробили спрощену систему оподаткування для чого?
Щоб податковий інспектор не мав от цього доступу до таких дрібниць! Навіщо?
Ми ж не на мільйони торгуємо? Ми спокійно працюємо в невеликих магазинах з малими сумами.
Я зараз як журналіст працюю на 3-ій системі спрощеного оподаткування. Коли будуть введені касові апарати,
то коли я робитиму якісь публікації, я повинен теж якимось чином, не зрозуміло яким, вибивати чек.
Як це можна зробити?! Цього ніхто не знає!
Ми не в магазинах, у нас закупівля від населення сільгосппродукції - залишки,
що виростили бабусі, ми закупляли. Звідки ми можемо взяти документи вихідні?
Звідки первинна документація може бути? Це копійчаний бізнес! І зараз вони віднімають торбу в нищих!
Активісти руху Save ФОП звинувачують владу, що вона діє в інтересах великих компаній, які з чеками працюють вже давно.
Вибити конкурента з бізнесу таким чином дуже легко. Мікробізнес або піде в тінь, або закриється.
Відповідно великі мережі знають, що тоді до них клієнт перейде.
Ухвалюючи закон про касові апарати для ФОПів, Верховна Рада керувалася благородною метою:
детінізація бізнесу і прозорість оподаткування. Держава хоче змусити
тих, хто не сплачує всіх податків або працює за чорними схемами, вийти з тіні.
За розрахунками Міністерства економіки, рівень тіньової економіки
в Україні в 2019 році ставновив 28% від ВВП. А за даними МВФ, це число складає навіть 45%.
Це ще один пікет біля Верховної Ради. Учасників значно менше. Це представники здебільшого середнього та великого бізнесу -
продавці побутової техніки, автозапчастин, аптекарі, які вже раніше перейшли на касові апарати.
Вони  вимагають від влади не ухилятися від обраного шляху і не відтерміновувати введення касових апаратів для всіх.
Ми за те, щоб усі працювали в рівних умовах і сплачували податки, і щоб у нашого пацієнта була гарантія того,
що він купує якісні, нефальсифіковані лікарські засоби. А один із запобіжників - це і є фіскально-касовий чек,
який мають видавати в аптеці. Сьогодні в Україні понад 20тисяч аптек. Третина з них - ФОПи.
І саме вони домагаються, щоб знову працювати без фіскально-касових чеків.
Побутова техніка, прилади, комп’ютери: ринок електроніки в Україні - галузь номер один за обсягами контрабанди.
У цьому секторі лише мізерна частка підприємців працюють з касовими чеками.
Ось це фіскальний чек. Видно, що за товар купили. Інформація про цей фіскальний чек одразу відправлена в податкову.
Якщо в чеку немає коду магазину, назви товару, а просто значиться, що кошти сплачені,
це, стверджує підприємець В’ячеслав Склонний, пряма вказівка на те, що товар завезений в Україну нелегально.
Арифметику прозорого та тіньового бізнесу В’ячеслав пояснює, як для "чайників".
Товар за умовною ціною в 100 гривень завезено в Україну зі сплатою усіх мит і податків.
Ціна в продажі збільшується до 150-ти гривень. При цьому компанія-продавець заробляє 18 гривень. Так робить легальний бізнес.
А це той самий товар вартістю в 100 гривень, ввезений в Україну без сплати мит, теж коштує 150 гривень.
Продавці заробляють більше, навіть роблячи знижки. Це чорна схема.
Конкурувати в таких умовах легальний бізнес не в змозі, каже В’ячеслав. Він виступає за введення касових апаратів
без будь-якого відтермінування - принаймні в його секторі бізнесу.
Я дуже сподіваюся, що здоровий глузд переможе, і ми підемо в напрямку Європи,
де нечувана ситуація, коли клієнту не дають чек у будь-якому закладі.
В Україні найгірша ситуація в Східній Європі щодо тіньового імпорту, щодо безладу, що твориться на ринках.
Власниця невеликого ресторану Світлана Кравченко підтримує намагання держави вивести бізнес із тіні.
Але вважає, що встановлення касових апаратів у таких, як вона, дрібних підприємців, нічого не змінить.
Вибачте мене, якщо через митницю заходить лівий товар, то яким боком мій ресторан до цього товару?
Можливо, давайте почнемо з митниці, наведемо там лад для того, щоб не заходив сюди якийсь віскі лівий!..
Під час епідемії коронавірусу свій ресторан Світлана перекваліфікувала на дистанційне харчування,
возить на замовлення обіди та сніданки в офіси. Світлана розуміє, що якщо Верховна Рада не змінить законодавство,
їй доведеться працювати на виїздах з касовими апаратами. Відповіді, як це має виглядати на практиці, у законі вона не знайшла.
Хоче, щоб нардепи вийшли на діалог з дрібними підприємцями і якось доопрацювали закон.
Аби касові апарати на додачу до коронавірусу не добили українські ФОПи.